Jenny I want to come home I'm not like
super uber fat but I'm in a zone where
I'd like to drop 30 prob Kirsty is happy
to be back with Jenny Craig after all it
did the trick back in two thousand four
helping her lose 75 pounds Jenny Craig
was so successful for me because I need
I need to be accountable and I don't
have the highest responsibility when it
comes to staying steady the course as we
all know Rob yeah well you can go yeah a
little off track sometimes I get off
track when I don't follow the rules but
i liked it i have this consultant
because she helps me follow the rules
but since parting ways with jenny six
years ago to establish her own organic
liaisons food line products jenny craig
will now use Kirsty's weight has
certainly fluctuated and jenny
spokesperson valerie bertinelli has also
gained putting on some of the 40 pounds
she lost back in two thousand seven
valerie not the only jenny craig earth
at has put some weight back on from
reich area another one the other
question I have we have big lives we're
women I understand that but I think
lying I know you have big live your we
have your babies out to dinner and
feeding his chocolate right gotta call
my consulting oh it's a tough life that
you leave but you do cash these big
endorsement checks and some of the
public thanks Walt once you cash that
big check you are held to a higher
standard you know for a long time maybe
forever what do you say to that god help
the child god help Rob yes you are held
to a higher standard do you accept that
responsibility I do you know we just
keep we just keep working it you know we
just keep working I think the most
important thing that anybody can think
of is in the terms of this arena is two
people should be where they want to be
if somebody really wants to be Chubb
then let him be job if they wanna be
skinny let him be skinny I think you got
to find that place for you that makes
you feel good I know Kirsty says what's
on her mind so I wasn't surprised when I
heard she went off on Twitter about the
bachelor Juan Pablo she tweeted I hate
blank he's a jerk straight up why were
you so disturbed it was just so creepy
when they had the bachelor at the end
you know after he chosen just deep and
he won't even say he loves her what is
wrong with you one Pablo for God's sakes
I love you
thank you whoo um that case mate he's
just being honest she didn't say he
loves no Rob he's not being honest he's
not you don't go in national TV I could
say I love you rob is that being
dishonest well I think did you love you
rod I'll uh drop but so much but we love
each other in a different way than say
the bachelor and his female daters are
our robber in any way apparently mm-hmm
what is your wife thing about that he
knows it's a brother-sister type of
block plus a satellite interview very
very soon haha okay